[音楽]
ありがとう
ございます
魔女の後に晴らすということで非常に
プレッシャーを感じてバクバクなんです
けれども
皆さん今日はようこそ
テレックスユーつくばに来ていただきまし
た
僕のトークを始めたいと思います
ということで東北大学の僕ITAにし
さっきも紹介あった通り言うんですけれど
も
現在
火星探査機及び月の探査機の研究をやって
おります
じゃあまず僕宇宙について色々あるんです
けど僕の大好きな
火星について
自分たちのご近所さんですね
河川について話していきたいと思います
僕だけじゃなくて
ご存知の方結構多いと思うんですけど
イーロンマスクさんとか
世界中の研究者が活性化成っていう風に
言っております
でこの下線どこにあるのかというと地球の
隣ですね
金星地球火星っていう風にあって
僕たちのすごく身近な惑星となっています
でなんでこの火星がそんなに面白いのか
いろんな人が
興味を持って
研究してるのか探査してるのかっていう
ことに関してなんですけどもまず
語り出すとキリがなくて僕1日使っちゃう
んですけど火星について話すとあの
面白い点がいくつかあって一番大きな疑問
として
火星にかつて生き物がいたのかどうかこれ
がいろんな人が今こぞって研究している
テーマになります
じゃあなんで火星に生き物がいたかって
言われてるかっていうとこれがかつて
火星の
姿だったんじゃないかって言われてるもの
で最新の緊急で
火星にはかつて海が存在したということが
明らかになってきております
地球ほど深い海ではないにせよ
すごい広い範囲で水が存在したとじゃあ水
が存在してたってことは
生き物がいた可能性が十分あってで今稼ぎ
は水とか
表面にはないんですけれども
例えば地下とかに潜ってったら何か自分
たちの見たこともないような生き物が
こんな感じで
現れるかもしれないということで世界中の
人たちが今緊急をしているわけです
でこの火星を探査する歴史について
僕の好きな3つのミッションを紹介したい
んですけどまず1997年NASAの
ワールドプラスファインダーという
ミッションが行われましたこの時持ってっ
たのが
ソジャーナっていうローバルになります
老婆っていうのはここにありますように
車輪がついてて
火星上を走りながらいろんなものを調べる
探査機になります
これが近場ですけれども動き回って火星の
写真を撮って地球に送ってきたわけですね
この大成功を受けて今後どんどん稼いに
ものを持っていこうというふうに皆さんに
なりました
そして2012年かの有名なキュリオシー
です
知ってる方も多いと思うんですけど
すごく大きな探査機を火星に持っていき
ましたこのキュリオシティは
もともとのコンセプトとして
火星に研究室を持っていこうと
研究室丸ごと持ってっちゃうっていう
コンセプトを作った
ローバーで
元々の名前は
鳥ですのでカフェにラボ持って行こうぜっ
ていうコンセプトで作ってこれも現役で今
でも炭酸続けております
[拍手]
で2021年去年ですね
現在でも現役で探索の炭酸を続けており
ますこのパンセミナンスの大きな成功とし
て
uap
ドローンみたいなものですね
インジケーキというのが完成に行ったん
ですね
写真に載ってますけれどもこれが実際に
稼いで飛行することを成功させたと
現在までに33回ぐらい
飛ぶことに成功してて今後活性でどんどん
飛ぶような炭酸できるんじゃないかって
言われててこれ結構すごいことであんまり
印象わからないと思うんですけど
例えたら地球ではないと兄弟が
初めて飛行機を開発して飛んだとそれが今
の旅客機につながってるわけじゃないです
かなので今は稼いでヘリコプターが飛ぶ
時代なのでどんどん飛ぶようなパンツ今後
出てくるだろうっていう風に言われてます
それで現在の最新の
探査ミッションなんですけれども今世界中
の研究者が目指しているのはサンプリター
ミッションで
火星に行って
砂とか
岩石そういったものを回収してロケットに
積んで
地球まで戻ってこようと
持ってこようとこういったミッションを今
検討してやっている最中です
では
火星の最新の
探査ミッションに行ったところでじゃあ僕
は何をやってるのか
前売りする一言で
火星uabと
ロバイについて研究してるんでそれについ
て話したいと思います
まず僕学部生の頃このインジニティの
ヘリコプターの影響を受けまして
自分でも火星で
飛ぶようなものを作ってみたいとそういっ
た新しい研究がやりたいってことでこんな
感じで
火星のヘリコプターのデザインとかそう
いったものをやりながら緊急をしていまし
たそれで実際に開発したヘリコプターが
こういったものになります僕これ黒くて
かっこいい遊びだって呼んでるんです
けれどもこのヘリコプター作って実際に
緊急やっていたわけです
じゃあこれが活性で一体どのように飛ぶの
かということなんですけれども
こういった感じで河川飛ぶんじゃない
かってこれが予想動画になります
実際にこれが火星に行きましてじゃあ
NASAのヘリコプターと何が違うのって
いう点なんですけどこれは
交差反転って呼ばれる
クロスした形の
全く新しい今までにない方式を採用してて
これを火星に持ってってこんな感じで
クロスして飛ぶんですよ本当にこれを火星
に持って行って飛んだらより遠くに行ける
んじゃないかより自分たちが調べたい
縦穴とか
言ったことないような場所に行けるんじゃ
ないかっていうことでこういった緊急探査
をずっとやってきました
実際にこのように稼いですごい遠くまで
飛べるんじゃないかっていうふうに
僕は考えています
で今ではこの化成ヘリコプターの研究だけ
ではなく
東北大学でこういったさっきのふりをして
みたいなローバーを使ってもういろんな
ローバーの開発研究をやっていてこれが
もう作ったローパーの一つになります
こんな感じで現在は研究を続けています
じゃあ僕の研究を話したところで
宇宙のガチガチの話だけじゃなくてクレイ
スってことで
NASAとかJAXAの大御所がやってる
ミッションだけじゃなくて
宇宙でなんか面白いミッションないのって
ことで色々話したいんですけどまず話した
のがこの天下のレッドブル様ですこの天下
のレッドブルさんも何をやったかと言い
ますと人をですね
気球に乗せて宇宙まで持ってきますそこ
から飛び降りようと
使いタイミングをやらせたわけですねこれ
宇宙からこの人飛び降ります
本当に頭おかしいチャレンジで
レッドブル本当翼を授けてしまったんです
けど人にこれ動画見るとめちゃくちゃ怖い
です
自分が落ちるんじゃないかって感覚になる
動画があるんですけど
ぜひ見てみてくださいこんな感じでレッド
ブルチャレンジをやりましたこれ実際にね
宇宙飛行士みたいになって宇宙に行ってる
んですけどすごい面白いミッションでした
で次に話したのがテスラっていう
先ほど僕が1体イーロンマスクさんが作っ
た電気自動車の会社なんですけどじゃあ
電気自動車宇宙と何の関係があるんだって
話なんですが
実はこのテスラの
ロードスターというモデルをですね宇宙に
吹っ飛ばしてしまったんですねこれ実際に
宇宙にあります今車が宇宙にあります
ロケットとかに搭載して
宇宙に行くのは人工衛星だけだっていう
固定概念があるんですけどそれだけじゃ
なくて車も宇宙に飛んでるとこれなんで
こんなことしたのかっていう
感じなんですけれども
色マスターに開発がしたロケットに
積むペイロード何を積むのかってところで
問題があってじゃあ
車のスって持ってっちゃおうということで
実際に伸ばしてしまったのがこの
ミッションになりますこれにはなんか多額
の良さもかかってるしなんでこんな余計な
何の意味もないことするんだっていう風な
世界中で言われたんですけどさすがね
色マスクさんですね
知ったこっちゃないと
[音楽]
面白いことやりたいんだ挑戦したいんだ
僕たちは気にしない
世の中金ですねお金もればこんな
車持ってきるってことですね
でこの搭載して飛ばしてったらロケットは
このスペースXって会社まあ色マスクさん
が作ったロケットの会社なんですけれども
このスペースXの会社何をやってるかって
いうとまずこのパートナーンっていう
ロケットですねまあ一般的にはロケットに
見えるんですが何がすごいかっていうと
このロケット宇宙に行って
役割を終えたら戻ってきて着陸するんです
必要なものを届けて戻ってきて着陸しこれ
着陸ポットもこれ船なんですよ船の上に
ロケットが着陸するとでなんで戻してき
たかっていうとこれを再利用するためです
ね
9回飛ばすことができます
それだけじゃなくて今はスターシップって
いうこの何百人も乗れるようなロケットを
作ってますじゃあなんで何百円もこのよう
なロケット作るんで自分たち乗れないじゃ
ないかっていうのがあるんですけどエロ
マッサさんに考えてるのレッツゴー
トゥモローですねあの
数年前に本とかで出てたあの
火星移住計画ってまあ夢物語みたいなの
ありましたけどさこれ本当に実現しようと
してますあの
色マスクさんのスペースXに行くと
火星の縦膜があって
実際に稼いに行こうぜみたいなセリフが
書いてあります本当にこの人に人類移住さ
せることを目指しています
でその証拠にこれが現在に宇宙飛行士の姿
ですスペース600って言うんですけど
こんな近未来が宇宙服を着て
実際に宇宙に行くことを
目指して今宇宙飛行士たちがこれで実際に
行ってるっていう感じになります
じゃあアメリカの話だけじゃなくて日本
なんかやってないのってことで
ジャクソとか言ってた思いといて
ロケット風邪ってことで
istインターステラテクノロジーズの話
をしたいと思いますこのインスタンス
テクノロジーが作ったロケットがこちらに
なります
ねってことで
宇宙に飛ばすものの意味合いが変わって
くるだろうといったところであるんです
けれどもそういう話一旦置いといて
実際に100キロ宇宙まで行くような
ロケットを開発してどんどん日本からも
ファンキーで
挑戦的なロケットを作っていこうという
感じで
民間企業も頑張っています
じゃあ
フューチャーということで将来どうなって
いくのかっていうことについて話したいん
ですけど
じゃあ今までこう
移動手段について話したいんですが
元々人間は馬車とかそれ動物を使って移動
してましたこれが
車とか鉄道になるわけですね今でも主流の
交通次第になって
で飛行機が出てきて
旅客機とかで今
世界中に飛べれるようになったとでこれが
将来的には
宇宙宇宙に
惑星感を意識できるような時代が来るん
じゃないですかこれが本当に言われており
ます
で今スペースXしっかり世界中がこぞって
好走してるのがこの月面に基地を作
るってことです
月面に基地を作って先ほど言ってたスター
シップとかでどんどん人を送って生き生き
させるとで月面基地から火星まで行くと
そういったミッションを考えているわけ
です
本当に
負のですねどう言って未来が待ってるん
だろう
例えばこんな感じで大学の教授が来てです
ね
来週はちょっと火星に行くんでちょっと
休校になりますみたいなここ突拍子もない
こと言い出したり
こんな
感じでLINEでね
月集合しよう一旦月行こうみたいだって今
LINEでねアメリカに十字到着する
みたいなことできますもんねこれがもう
宇宙になるんじゃないかと
さらに言えば
火星から商品を
届けてもらうと
火星をオリジナルの何かを地球まで送って
きて
玄関に活性から作られて何かを加えてくる
とそういった面白い時代がやってくるん
じゃないかってことが言われてます
じゃあここで僕が何をやってるか何を
目指してるのかって話したいんですけど
僕はこういうローバーとかがヘリコプター
が好きでそういった研究をやりつつ
宇宙飛行士になると目指しております
実際に宇宙飛行士になるのを
目指して頑張るために
ポーランドで開かれるアナログミッショ
ンっていう
宇宙飛行士が本当に
訓練みたいな参加して世界中の人たちと
協力してやったり左上の写真ですね
もしくは国際宇宙大学と呼ばれる2ヶ月が
ポルトガルで開かれたんですけど
世界中のね
若手研究者が集まって
みんなで研究の話とかこれからの宇宙の話
とかそういったものをする会議に参加し
たり
様々な学会で発表したり日々自分を磨く
ために頑張っているわけですじゃあ最後
締める流れとして僕が宇宙飛行士に目指し
て
英語で世界に発信して
終わりにしたいと思います
[拍手]